- [Voiceover] Li Min squeezed
three lemons to make lemonade.
She squeezed 42 millimeters of lemon juice
from the first lemon.
36 milliliters of juice
from the second lemon,
and 45 milliliters of juice
from the third lemon.
How much lemon juice did Li MIn
squeeze from her three lemons?
Well we just have to add
how many milliliters she got
from each of them, add them all together.
So from the first one,
she got 42 milliliters
42, and short for milliliters I can write
lowercase m for mili, and
uppercase L for liters.
42 milliliters from the first lemon.
36 milliliters from the second lemon,
and then 45 milliliters
from the third lemon.
So we can just add these
three quantities together.
So let's do that, let's add them together.
So we're gonna get something
in terms of milliliters.
So let's go first to the ones place.
Two plus six is eight,
eight plus five is 13.
13 is three ones and one 10,
so I could write that
one 10 in the 10s place.
So one plus four is five,
plus three is eight,
plus four is 12, so it's gonna be 12 10s.
Which is the same thing as 120.
So in total, Li Min
squeezed 123 milliliters
from her three lemons.
Let's do another problem like this.
Sarah poured five cans of motor oil
into the container below.
So this container below has 55,
let's see this is halfway, it's filled up
after she poured the five cans,
and it's filled up
halfway between 40 and 50,
so this mark right here, this
looks like that would be 45.
So it's filled up to 45 milliliters.
So she poured five cans,
and those five cans combined
ended up being 45 milliliters.
All of the cans held
the same amount of oil,
and I guess we can assume that
this container below was empty
before she filled any of the cans in.
So all of the cans held
the same amount of oil.
How many milliliters of
motor oil were in each can?
So she had five cans, so one,
one can, two cans, three cans,
four cans, and five cans.
They each had a certain
amount of oil in them.
And when she put them
all in, so let's say they
each have a question mark of oil in them.
So she had five cans, and
they each had a question mark
amount, say question mark
milliliters of oil in it.
And when you multiplied by five,
when you put all five together
you got 45 milliliters.
You got 45 milliliters.
So five times what amount of oil per can
would get us to 45 in total?
Well five times nine is 45.
So this thing right over here,
five times nine is 45.
So Sarah had nine milliliters in each can,
they each had the same
amount, they say that.
All the cans held the same amount of oil.
So if she had nine milliliters
in each one, notice,
if in each of the five cans
you had nine milliliters,
five times nine is 45.
So she had nine milliliters
of motor oil in each can.